geht es doch ein spiegel
[Musik]
hallo mein name ist programm meine
lieben freunde ich darf euch heute recht
er hat dich willkommen zu einem und
richtig krank und video zwar waren keine
ruft uhr allerdings nicht jetzt
sondern wir schauen uns einem tor von
mir selber an von vor sechs jahren also
und herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen aus einer
etwas anderen positionen einfach so ein
muscle shirt tanktop angezogen was
eigentlich nur so muskelprotz zum tragen
ich entschuldige mich erst mal dafür
dass ich total fertig aussehen dass
meine augen rot sind dass ich auch nur
so nur noch 15 mäßig angezogen bin ja
jetzt besser gar nichts angezogen
anstatt er in jeans hemd mit einem
blauen tanktop bruder war ich will gar
nicht das was ich später findet dann
hatte ich war gestern bei holy festival
hat mir dabei auch sehr weh getan und
zwar so war herr van gaal das tut alles
heftig werden nämlich in brennnesseln
gefallen und bin jedenfalls zumal ganzen
beide wären meine reaktion hat ein
kumpel von mir sogar wunderschönen das
doch wie fest sie will ich weiß nicht
mehr genau wo das war also der haut fest
wir sind ja diese läuft musik oder
schweißen alle farben rot und blau man
trinkt und ich bin ein trainer sein
ja das ist meine schmutz ecke da kommt
alles sind sowie leere flaschen oder so
meisten stehen der bionade holunder
flaschen ich liebe bier oder wenn ich
mir eine freude machen wollte mit
bionade holunder infekt
[Musik]
zwei tage später nachdem ich das video
hochgeladen habe haben
zuschauerinnen bei mir geklingelt und
meiner mutter bionade holunder geschenkt
süß aber auf der anderen seite war es
auch bisschen krieg dann können wir hier
ein wenig weiter umgehen
es findet sich dann mein bisschen sieht
immer noch genauso aus
mein bett sieht immer noch 1 1 genau so
aus hier hat sich gar nichts aber
wirklich gar nichts verändert das ist
magic happens
[Musik]
als das video hochgeladen hast warst du
die einzige magic die da passiert es war
mit deiner abend davor stehen
[Musik]
diese tasche
wenn ich mich selber sehen würde
die ich halt immer hinwollten
rechtzeitig zur schule und so bissig
bruder du bist auf ein gymnasium
gegangen in die elfte klasse was es da
so viel mit business zu tun wie mein
youtube kanal mit guten content wo hier
habe ich so sachen wie sport oder liegen
ein schrank mach ich mal ganz schnell
hier guck doch wunderschön
warum machst du ganz schnell zeigt doch
einfach und wie wenig klamotten hat sich
übrigens auch mittlerweile ist meine an
kleider so groß wie ein fußballfeld
dann ist das hier so mein bett mit
meinem bettbezug und da habe ich so ein
bild von manhattan
[Musik]
ich weiß auch ganz genau
ich wollte erst new york sagen aber dann
dachte ich mir ich war ja schon mal da
ich bin ein local ich sag manhattan
waren abschuss überall hier so ein paar
kettchen faust man sich da mal hinsetzen
möglich da saß nie jemand in diesem
bereich kennt er wahrscheinlich schon
das meiste video und wartet da muss man
direkt stoppen
jetzt mal hier das war der klassische
schule mal für die kamera und ich wusste
wo sie jeden sollten aber selber war es
gibt diesen auf der einen seite spricht
dafür dass man sie direkt wieder den
takt auf der anderen seite aber hoffen
wir dass ich die kleiner strand kommen
mann
musste mal gesagt werden die arbeiten ja
nicht vollzeit youtube ich bin ja
studierende und ihr mittlerweile mit
studieren noch nicht mehr schüler luca
war es da noch nicht studenten das hast
du am ersten sechs 2014 hochladen
dann begann am ersten neun abschlossen
kleinen tisch wo ich so ein paar
schreibt sachen drauf wieder was
ein ipod nano ipod nano mit dem ich auf
dem ich sehr sehr viele max es drauf
habe und es damit immer so ein bisschen
höhere mixes
dj befindet sich hier meine beiden
mischpults bzw
ein kompressor mischpult und mehr normal
ist mit spult das also
mal ganz kurz bruder du hast überhaupt
keine ahnung davon denn dieses setup was
du da hast ergibt absolut überhaupt gar
keinen sinn
ich weiß noch ich wollte in dem video
aber so einen auf ich hab ahnung von dem
was ich mache
das ist eine softbox hier zurzeit noch
eine provisorische ampel nicht alt und
gewinnst bist du eine professionelle
softbox eine online was ist das für eine
kamera da ich weiß echt ich
wer mich damals abonniert hat
mittlerweile 34 jahre alte mit meinen
kopfhörern drauf das ist einfach so sie
merkt
das thema professionalität angeht hat
sich in den letzten sechs jahren
eigentlich nichts getan einfach so
sachen die ich halt so alltäglich
benutze mein macbook wenn ich mich da
draußen ist nämlich über das macbook
trinken tue ich auch täglich es ist
krass wie viel man hier lernt über den
menschen luca 18 und hier und deshalb
ein bisschen kabel gewöhnt aber ich weiß
das ganze minimalistisch zu halten
b
hast du jeden einen plan davon gehabt
von was du da überhaupt redest du hier
eine lampe die ich auch an machen kann
[Musik]
immer diese scheiss youtuber mit ihren
milliarden auf dem konto
die haben dann auch noch lampen die man
machen kann ja hier auch wieder so ein
bisschen was grün ist alles unecht weil
das sonst als bei mir sterben würde
da ist meine brille und ich habe
gleichzeitig mir was unter 16
bei der nintendo 3ds spiele konsole sehr
sehr warmen wie nintendo 3ds spiele
konsole
du sagst auch ordentlich hey das ist
mein iphone mobile endgeräte receiver
sich einen receiver liebe diese
fußballer von ikea damit kann man dann
von letzterem laufen immer spielen
[Musik]
ich habe einfach meine aufnahme gerade
aus geschossen von dummheit baum
gefallen oder was noch da bin ich halt
[Musik]
eine brille die ich gestern noch holly
festival gefunden habe davon hey ich
wiege mich darin wohl ich kann das ja
mal ein paar fotos gerade einwänden von
holly festival
[Musik]
ich habe so viele bilder gemacht aber
erst waren wir auf allen hacke stramm
und zweitens hatte ich einfach keinen
bock die da einzufügen tastet er sich
sehr auf seine nase putzen musste so und
sonst ist hier um ein longboard mir
einfach ein longboard gekauft
weil die ganzen youtuber das vorgemacht
haben
und ich dachte mir
ja
fahre ich immer rum
nie gemacht hier sind noch handeln liebe
nicht eigentlich nicht sehr viel machen
aber man muss sich ja sportlich sein
dass man ist ja auch schon sportlich
wenn ihnen einfach nur liegen habe auch
faszien rolle habe ich mir jetzt geholt
und sonst würde
sagen hier ist auch ein spiegel hallo
na bitte
spart euch die kommentare per sieht cool
aus wie ich euch wenn es euch gefallen
hat und so hat es nicht
und wir wollen auch nicht mehr wenn euch
allerdings meine reaktion auf meine
linke 2014 gefallen hat dann lasse gerne
einen daumen hoch unter video da
schreibt einfach und in die kommentare
wie in meinem zimmer damals fanden
abonniert main kanal falls doch keinen
teil der lupus und hey ich wiege mich da
drin
[Musik]